let's talk about Cox wait wait wait
we've got a pre-roll first Gina take her
down a notch all right this episode is
brought to you by Buffy Thank You Buffy
for sponsoring us today their latest
project progress their latest product
the breeze is made entirely from 100%
eucalyptus fiber to keep you all cool
yeah it keeps you actually really cool
and comfortable
you're like a koala bear in my bed so
like if you have a husband and like
Steve who just wakes up in a pool of his
own bodily fluids every day Rose this
would be great for you because you see
what it's a comforter comforter it keeps
you cool not super oh so like I'll feel
snug and happy yeah taken care of
yeah not smothered one of those yeah
well who bows for $20 off your Buffy
comforter visit Buffy co-ceo
and enter promo code b tch and you will
get $20 off that's a huge summer's
coming up we need this I just want the
comforter yes yeah all right and welcome
back to hey [ __ ] podcast hey you less
girls than we did the first episode but
hopefully you like it and if you keep
watching those girls will come back or
their faces will rotate it so keep and
subscribe keep doing it rate us on
iTunes if you're listening on Apple you
know do all that stuff it really helps
us out we want six stars yes we want sex
stars that's what we're talking about
today sex very relatable topic first off
who's here
roll call really quick oh sorry yeah oh
sorry
oh my god I just I'm gonna cry I'm just
kidding what's up what's hood it's your
boy bows and this is Tiffany yay and
we're all here to talk about not just
sex but the worst sex we've ever had we
would talk about literally my entire sex
life Oh open I mean you want me to open
up the can well right the thing is is
that like in the group text I feel like
this is where I was like all these girls
are chill because it's all sloppy and
everyone thinks that I
everyone else is having great sex or
they know how to do it exactly right and
nobody knows what the [ __ ] they're doing
okay and so these stories are to like
help you feel like you're not alone just
I just know that you're not alone yeah
those alright look let me start by
saying this the sex does not end after
y'all get out of bed it's not over yet
at least not for all women what what
depends the next two days are also a
factor how do you treat me after that oh
yeah oh yeah count the sexual experience
well as like the week that you had sex
in the hole the week before how did you
court me how did you do the do and how
did you treat me and what are those
girls that needs like a whole birthday
week well it's more like for me for me
personally I you know like prior to my
current relationship I'm in I'd never
had good sex before in my life oh my
goodness I never had but it's also
because I'm not an overly sexual person
I was a very insecure girl and so I'm
like we are having sex because you will
like me once we have interfere as a way
to kind of like it was someone it was
more so like this is what we're supposed
to do like I've never been like a very
sexual person so there was a lot of
emotion and like the before and after
it's tied up into it but I probably I
you know looking back now that I know
the difference like I probably have had
some poor experiences I mean yeah have
you guys not I have absolutely yeah I
kind of was in the same boat as you were
I just thought all sex was like man
because it was just something you did in
the relationship yeah and I never
thought it was a whole like I didn't get
people that were like sexual and like
they crave sex and they're very
passionate about it to me it was just
like oh yeah I mean my boyfriend do that
until I had good sex and then after that
I wouldn't settle for anything less than
good today it changes a person it's like
if you if you like you're a crazy and B
have only bad sex and I know there are
some people out there that relate to it
and I'm just being [ __ ] real you're
literally laying in bed and you're like
do you like me yet yeah
like if you think sex is man you are
having bad sex oh yeah yeah yes that's
like I think you have to actually like
you have to get into a relationship
where you have a deep connection what
the purse
like y'all ever had like icons yeah yeah
yeah I'm like I'm like we literally feel
like your heartbeats are in sync okay
well you're more romantic you're in love
and [ __ ] you tip was like a bad sex was
it when it wasn't romantic definitely
and I was I'm in the same boat as you
Nikki or I feel like I my entire sex
life my whole experience with sex was
always like oh this is what it's like no
goal and then but yeah not until Kacey
was the first time that I ever did have
like that connected like amazing like
like I said you feel your heart beats in
sync because it's just so like you're so
the whole body vibrates yeah like you're
just so present and it just feels like
whoa like it really like I get it when
people say like to become one kind of
thing or some ice girls like that yeah I
love that song yeah it's like a whole
you know and you know what's funny about
it too I've heard this you could I've
heard this from so many guys like I know
y'all have heard this [ __ ] before two
guys have said like oh yeah when I lost
my virginity it wasn't as good as I
thought it was gonna be like a lot of
guys were so excited for the moment to
have sex and then like they were like
allows that was okay like I did it it
should hurt because I'm foreign and they
just think it's gonna be like this that
issue so so the the one guy that I had
like the worst relationship like sex
wise with he actually was addicted to
porn no he had this idea of like sex
needs to be like what I watch all the
time like everybody like he got to
desensitize to sex so I got to the point
where we would like we couldn't even get
intimate anymore
oh no whenever it would start so he'll
we didn't even start
you only get off if you show up in a
pizza delivery outfit yeah like that
right I mean I didn't even know this
about him like he just kind of kept that
part of himself a secret until it got in
think it became an issue in the bedroom
because we literally like could not even
get anything going
it was it like that in the beginning -
um no so that's this that's the reason
why I should
yeah in the beginning it's always
exciting so you're always just like all
over each other you're just any time you
want it you see each other you just have
to [ __ ] because it's just so new and so
exciting yeah
so in the beginning I didn't know that
until like he got more comfortable and
that's when things was started really
surfacing where I'm like hold on what's
happening here like you know you can't
even get the motor started and you're
like what's wrong with me like you can
tell that he's not present look let me
just say there was one time that you
know I was I was down I was down and I
look up and he was like looking at the
ceiling and I was immediately I was like
so we're done here right make like no
noise under one time a guy fell asleep
inside me he was on top of me and then
he was like [ __ ] six-foot-one I'm
like yo dude yeah oh you want to get off
man because like [ __ ] it whatever I'm
tired too and then we just went to sleep
gross yeah he just fell asleep what was
it like it was it a casual encounter
boyfriend okay I lost my virginity to my
boyfriend he was at all like freshmen
you know like and they're all skinny
when they're Danny and like he was like
you put it in I was like at that kind of
hurts and like a feat like a few minutes
later I'm like hello oh no I really fell
asleep position was not moving he like
dead waited on top of me because it was
like 4:00 in the morning I see my hell
is on a school night you know that's how
I lost my virginity to look into his
house yeah yeah so yeah and then fell
asleep on top of me I was like all right
well whatever then see and it's like
like that you don't even think about it
really that much and you don't think of
it as like a bad sex story but then
later on you're like that wasn't good
no that's what I'm saying if you have
never if you're just like if out there
thinking oh I'm just not a sexual person
you need to go have grab because lately
makes you look back at everything and be
like wow I had sex all wrong like I
thought that I had it figured out like
penis goes in vagina we know it also
affects you a lot like mentally is if
you grow up in a really conservative
household where sex is shameful yes
that completely [ __ ] up your view on
sex like totally you know [ __ ] wild I
thought I was having the best sex ever
because I was so in love with this guy
you know what I mean so I was dating
this guy for like a year and a half or
so and I thought it was the best sex
ever I was like [ __ ] I gotta do no works
he loved being on top which is great and
it was cool like for some reason it
always worked and then we broke up for
you and then we got back together and
then we got back together for a while
like he was like he was gonna propose
all right goodness and then I realized
late no the sex is kind of shitty now
because in our relationship it kind of
like I started seeing more things about
him that I was like I don't want to
marry this yeah so then I started
realizing like this was never great I
just really liked you a lot because I
realized our sex was super duper routine
yeah as in he'd come home from work I
have dinner ready cuz I'm wifey and [ __ ]
right oh yeah like I can be wifey so I
had to have dinner ready and then we go
to bed we watch HGTV because we're like
oh my god and then so it was so routine
he could not get hard unless I sucked
his dick first so it had to start off
with a [ __ ] every time so there was
no spontaneous sex in the middle of
whatever because I would always have to
say did he reciprocate yeah he would
every like I'll go get in said that
later but and then it would be him
hidden it missionary and if we're
feeling [ __ ] wild like if we're
feeling crazy that night
then we'll [ __ ] doggy style and that's
like wild for us and then he comes and
that's it and because I'm not the type
that needs to come every time I don't
really care much as I know I'm hella
complicated like it's hard to yeah from
sex oh that's a misconception guys think
come or there's magic Lum during sex all
the time I know you need that quick
correlation yeah yeah so I didn't so I
didn't even make him make me [ __ ] every
time so for like every 12 times he came
I would actually come once which is fine
like I neveri time you say the c-word
I'm like every time every time I climax
yeah so then like towards the end of our
relationship when he like one day he
told me he was like cuz he was a
sneakerhead he's like should I buy these
shoes I'm like no it's not that great he
goes yeah you're right I should be
saving for the ring and instead of
getting excited I was like picturing
your future of 40 years of [ __ ] this
way yeah and I actually in my head was
thought I thought like well I mean after
a while people have to start or stop
having sex anyway so maybe I'll be okay
oh my god and then that's when I
realized I'm like I can't do this I
can't do this I can't do this and then
broke up with him and then dated a guy
afterwards is that is still by far like
the best sex I've ever had in my life
yeah see that's why I think these
stories are important too because
someone out there listening right now
might be having sex that way and they're
like oh [ __ ] I'm doing it wrong my girls
not pleased but to be honest that's
exactly how Steven I have sex every time
like I give them a by government [ __ ]
and it's hard we do missionary if we're
feeling well we'll do doggy but honestly
it's the best [ __ ] sex of my life
everybody you guys always seem happy
yeah yeah I really connect thought it
would have been like that because if I
was just described to you before what I
thought the best sex ever was yeah it'd
be just like tossing all around all
these different position when I fit so
great great is the connection coupled
with the dirty talk he did he liked the
way that I like to have sex or the thing
that turns me on the most is like
feeling dominated completely rich and I
know brother goofy dude just like yeah
usually become [ __ ] our friends for
four years before we started dating I
never would have imagined anyway he's
always kind of nerdy to me but ya know
he's like you turn it on then hands down
and stuff and yeah and then his dick was
really good yeah and so I think that in
the end it didn't really matter the
positions
that we were doing and he just felt the
best with him on top and him doing like
all the work and stuff and and I like
giving head in the beginning because it
makes me feel like like I'm like I am
submissive yeah yeah and so I wouldn't
have guessed that and it's just
different strokes for different folks
foreplay is so important the dude that I
was routine with it was there was no
foreplay it was just like hey mama you
have sex and like foreplay is asking
button that you can put like the couples
in your night yeah on the nightstand and
it's like if you're down you just hit
the button like if the buttons sync up
and it's like woo time for sex but you
just like looked at it the lights a
plastic cover I was gonna tell this like
story but it's not even a story because
I've never told it before so I don't
even know how this is gonna come out but
we're ready when you were talking about
like being submissive so I'm like I'm
very much a switch I'm like very 50/50
like I will beat your ass and get my
Aspen Ham no like 100% right but I've
always been very dominant and I knew
that I was always dominant but like one
day I felt like this like this a little
bit of femininity and I was like I think
I want to be submissive and I was dating
this guy hey this is so [ __ ] funny to
me but it was not funny to him so I was
much younger and this guy was older than
me right and like you keep in mind I
look like a toddler and so and this
guy's like 6 1 like whatever and we in
like I realized that I liked being more
submissive but like I had never watched
I never watched porn or anything like
sex was very like shamed in my house but
I knew that I had this like femininity
that I kind of wanted to like come out
and so like we were like in this like
kind of like playground area one day we
were like all emo kids and so like we
were in this like we're outside of his
apartment complex and I was like I want
you to slap me oh it was like he was
like what and I was like I think I liked
it I was like because one time like you
did something kind of dominant and I was
like I think I want you to slap me and
so like we're outside like in public but
like nobody's around like literally
nobody's here and he's like ok and so he
like slaps me and I'm like across your
face yeah and I'm like do it [ __ ]
hard yeah
and he was like he was like and like I'm
experimenting big yeah that's great
that's good and I'm like and I'm like I
was like I want you to slap me harder
and then he like it was the lightest tab
and then I was like come on little
[ __ ] baby I was like I'm trying to
bring out like this submission and then
like I was so turned off because like he
couldn't he couldn't fulfill that be
good and abuse a woman yeah what a bad
guy but like I didn't know like I had
never explored this thing before so I
was like I think I want to be slapped
over you I was like 18 like okay meaning
of like sex yeah like what you mean when
it's a turn-off because there was this
one time where I really wanted to be
choked out yeah I was just like just
[ __ ] choke me but like he would and
it would only last for like 30 second
I'm like any he's really sick cuz he
can't do two things at once like no like
[ __ ] choke me yeah it's a bummer
because you're like you're not if you're
not enjoying this I'm not enjoying this
yeah like at least like pretend like it
buddy like you know you can't I can't do
the whole like I'm scared to hurt you I
respect like moment now when we're
asking for it yeah I want to be
disrespected and beat yeah I like
sometimes sometimes you literally you
know it's a very like primitive thing
we're like it's not necessarily that we
want to be disrespected it's that we
want to feel possessed yeah yeah owned
we want to feel like yeah and sometimes
that is a kind of skewed or alternative
form of feeling love yeah you know but
someone is like the big one above us
exactly I love that like being little
spoon I like the otech tits yeah yeah
well on that note we are gonna take a
quick break and when we come back we're
gonna hear our very worst sex stories
sure if you like being dominated the
best way to get dominated by your man is
to cook him a meal how about hello fresh
would you also like $80 off of hello
fresh oh I would I love the deal oh oh
yeah Gina what we get in with that I'm
just saying that you [ __ ] better on a
full stomach and sometimes people just
want to jump into it and these meals
only take 30 minutes to make and
everything
pre-packaged see like that Segway huh
that was ever like packages all the
ingredients are shipped to you
prepackaged pre-measured so all you got
to do is dump it into the pot and make
it it's actually really good I had this
for a few months and I loved it it me
still have it yeah right it makes it
looks like you have your [ __ ] together
that way you get in the pants even
easier they think you know what you're
doing the best part is if you don't know
cook it's already prepped you got the
recipes it's delicious they don't even
have to know that it's hellofresh
or that you got it for $80 off and also
it doesn't even have to be for your man
make that [ __ ] for you there's family
meals and there's also vegetarians yeah
they have different diets diet ones I
like you get to pick out your meals each
week like on the website and you see all
the pictures where they're all prepped
and you're like I think I'll have
panteth your I don't know broccoli no I
want to pretend like I know what I'm
doing exactly perfect I just throw away
all the packaging so he thinks that you
actually made it yourself and then you
just get there you could trick yourself
as you're making it for yourself so for
our viewers today we have $80 off your
first month of hellofresh
you guys got a hello fresh calm a /bt CH
you guys will get $80 off your first
month which is basically receiving like
eight free meals so that's eight free
meals amazing for you and your Bonin
partner yeah and it's hellofresh calm
slash b tch and then you enter the code
b tch
80 bucks off and we're back are you
ready to get rocked yeah let's start
with that
all right so I was with this guy for a
couple years and so like our sex life
was it was alright like he was really
good when he ate me out it was amazing
but every time a game-changer yeah yeah
yeah I'm like you know what to do I feel
like a child because whenever it cuz you
guys are my friends and like yeah he
must going down I'm yelling no okay so
for me like for that subject it's like
you gotta use a mouth and your hands
like yeah to be a twofer you can't just
be like tongue only oh I'm a do fingers
can't I hate things so much I just
picture the fingernails and everything
under deal anyway so he was great in
that department but every time like he
actually his dick was pretty damn big
like it was just a lot of taken okay so
every time we would have she said it was
a lot every time we would die before it
but but yeah so after like okay we
couldn't even have sex for that long
because it would get to the point where
it started hurting all these all been
your cervix no like the outer Oh dried
up outside like stretchy stretc and then
it actually would create a rash oh yeah
yeah so I thought I was I thought I had
some like STD or some [ __ ] so I want to
go check it out and my doctor is like
nah you're good so I'm like what the
[ __ ] is this so then one day I was like
examining his dick I'm like what's going
on here and he had pubes at like the
base oh yeah yeah come out a lot so I'm
like maybe these pubes are [ __ ] me up
so then I told them once I Bank I'm like
make sure you clean like just clean
shave so then that happened and I still
would get these rashes at the end of it
so then I don't I still don't have a
conclusion you were allergic was dick
that's that's my conclusion to his dick
because as I could not have sex with any
more so like at all like allergic to
like the his sweat and like like some
kind of like hormone or pheromones there
no greeting from Nick body maybe ding it
actually developed because in the
beginning that didn't happen but I don't
know like towards the end I did just
even thinking of us trying to have sex
like my vagina would shudder cuz ya know
like and then so but it would get bad
because I would have to get an ice pack
and like wrap it around a towel and I
put it down there because oh my god it
was yet that just pubes have done that
to me before not that to that degree but
like where that's giving me a rash and
I'm like well I didn't know it was
causing it until I had like those people
that did that shaved it I'm allergic to
spermicide oh are you I'm already sure I
could get killed with sperm no problem
with you
Miller to it I put it on my wrist Oh
smart yeah well I would have never
thought to do that in my skin never know
yeah well I was like this stuff looks
like it could be my listen the skin on
my wrist swelled oh my god I was like
I'm so glad good for you and are we
testing it I do skin allergy test all
the time which also I highly suggest
anybody do that even if you don't have
sensitive skin it does not hurt to take
two seconds for a new product swipe it
on your wrist how long do you wait just
like five minutes Wow
I highly allergic it'll it'll happen
immediately I've never done anything
that I am so surprised I'm still alive
this long
sometimes we will like consume something
or you consume or you know put products
on and we don't even realize it we have
a very very mild allergy to them and we
do need to use them but if you do a
little test and you just even see a
streak of red you're like maybe this
isn't good for me you know if it's
flaring up your histamines or just
getting that system overworked and then
don't [ __ ] use it I'm allergic
aloe vera Wow yeah which is like the
thing that suits ya it makes it burns
and likes my skin on oh my god yeah it's
terrible I'm allergic to bad sex what
was your worst I would have to say the
worst sex ever had I was dating this guy
and I was doing my [ __ ] I was like I
was kind of being I was trying to be a
good person and I made him wait three
months because I was like you know what
like I heard that you know you shouldn't
put out too early you know what make
them wait for it make them work for it
whenever and for three months he
actually waited and you know the
relationship was cool and all
and then so I finally decide okay let's
have sex or one it was a very small dick
and I figured okay you know what it is
not about the size of the boat is the
whole motion thing right because it was
so small that if you were to grip it
with just your fist it would not pop out
pop you got to make it you got to
squeeze it till it pops
so I was like it's fine
and then we would have sex and then like
he'd be hidden from behind but here's
the thing so there's like there's a
wrong right way right so like say I'm
bent over you're supposed to be hitting
it from behind like sitting straight up
right right like sitting straight up
right this fool was hunched over on top
of me when you hunched over you're my
good dog
yeah so when you're hunched over on top
of me it pulls your his butt back so it
gives him even less yeah yeah and I was
like yo like this is the first time in
my life I was 24 years old I was like
wow I can't feel anything
oh wow yeah like I just could not feel
anything no matter what position it was
and I was like dude I [ __ ] what you
scissored him Yeah right like and I was
like I mean I waited three months for
this [ __ ] and from that point on I
was like you know what you test car that
or you test drive that [ __ ] car
before you buy it yeah I am for that
before marriage yeah exactly but then
the thing about him was that um I think
he kind of knew that he wasn't that big
because there he was holding out on you
yeah and then because during sex we'll
be like don't tell me how big it is I
had sex with the head of small dick like
that too that's all he wanted to hear
from me too yeah like yeah that feels
great huh I'm so big and I'm like damn
securities are not sexy I don't know
small dick and rock it but you got to be
confident with that yeah because he was
like you like that big dick and like it
just creates like a little bit of
confusion like an altar a small dick
learn how to rub it closer to her
clitoris that is what happen to make it
feel good like it or use your hand that
you don't have to use your dick yeah
don't use hands on me but if being
receptive to advice you because I even
told him like hey when your hand if or
behind can you like sit up straight you
know yeah and he'll do it like a couple
times and he'll never do to get him like
all right I'll be back straight
munication is so key so everyone
everybody's body parts are all shaped
different and it's awkward like I just
thought of good worse I have the worst
boy it just killed us but I get like
rumbled me I'm sorry I just came her to
my boy because you sent me a friend
request on facebook about a year ago I
rejected it and like so I don't know if
you're keeping up with the times or what
your Seekers been safe with me for a
long time until now you know this
happened but we just gonna glaze over it
so this wasn't even like at the sex like
this is actually the worst sex of my
life and there was a guy that I dated
so we his parents didn't like me and he
had he had like a pretty like decent
amount of money so like he would like
randomly be like baby let me take you
out to dinner and then we'll like go get
a hotel room or something and like and I
was like oh I can't like travel like an
hour out little staycation girl hotel
room and like I never was like - I don't
even remember much this was like years
ago the moment and we were sitting in
bed and like the there was some kind of
you know sometimes like you're not even
naked or anything but there's a vibe
like a little sexiness like you might be
about to have sexual thing and so like
we start getting closer and like he's
like I want you to first time you guys
are having son no no we've been dating
for a while but we've been up and down
and he was like I want you to rub my
stomach what like like like rub his like
stomach like you know how when you do
the thing where you like Pat your head
huh Robin he was like I want you to rub
my stone if you have a stomach did he
have abs or do you know he just like
that's important no I'm just like a
skinny little regular okay okay he was
said that he wasn't feeling well and he
said he wanted me to rub his stomach and
so I did it and I did it in a circular
motion he said no no that go the other
way like counterclockwise very specific
yeah and I was like okay and so like I
did it and we were watching TV and then
he curled up to me and he called me
Mommy oh yes a mommy Jaden pull up
inside of you Oh
his mind can go there cuz you know like
girls color guys yeah his mom used to
rub his stomach that exact way Wow
[ __ ] creepy done it's extra creepy if
he wanted to [ __ ] you right after this
is some yes and and now and we had
already been like I my vagina it was in
my nose both we broke up about a week
later because I was like I cannot I
cannot assist you know I cannot help I
cannot and like honestly there's there's
a thing in like the kind in that kind of
world that's like it's called like
gentle femme Dom which is like a man
likes to be like appreciated and like
hug and like stuff like that I get that
don't call me Mommy yeah like keepin
like keep it's yourself I don't I don't
I don't I honestly don't even care of
your [ __ ] thinking it like you know
I'll like I would like [ __ ] give me
head scratches back time in place like
women can be very nurturing people you
know and that's a different place then
right before sex
by far the worst reaction like what did
you say why you going home I basically
blacked out I mean like I spent the you
ended up having to no that's we did not
have sex and and here's the thing that I
don't even know if I should I don't know
we would would you guys have done the
situation because I immediately like I
remember I stopped touching him I kind
of just backed off and I was like whoa
like I said joke like whoa and like I
definitely made him feel very
embarrassed but I I couldn't do it you
can't throw that on someone yeah I look
at my vagina would make that window shut
down noisy
you can't throw that on someone
especially cuz it's such a weird fetish
you know like I mean there's a lot of
stepmom porn these days
poor hand that's a different you gotta
tell like party and I think the thing
was was that he was too in the zone
like he had his eyes closed and he felt
like his mother was about to [ __ ] him
and so like I had like oh it was like a
boner when you were rubbing is I don't
remember
I believe I've honestly detached from
the situation since then
yeah dishes are okay but you just have
to discuss a communication that is the
100% biggest factor in all of yeah it
just I thought getting my toes sucked
was a weird I was just gonna say that
boyfriend for five years and that was
the one that that had I had the boring
sex with I told you that I relate to
more was just the same routine each time
but also on top of that he sucked my
toes and he would um finger his belly
button what any kind of belly fetish run
like you mean like a [ __ ] middle-aged
fat like that trucker minded me of like
when we were young we were like
twenty-one and it reminded me of that
and it got to the point where I was so
turned off by having sex with this guy
that he would just beg to masturbate in
front of me oh I just wouldn't have sex
with him but that's not even my worst
story my worst story is the just a
question can you access the oh my god
that's a good question apparently and
you can see this within our stuff behind
the cameras crush
guys are watching this on youtube or if
you're listening to this on Spotify and
you can go to the youtube please let me
know can you access the male prostate
from the belly button yes I feel like
with some Jess she's like I've explored
every belly button and lost but my that
wasn't even the worst so my worst I know
right that was like a long slow worst
but this one was before you I want to
know how many times did he rub his belly
button in front of you Oh every time I
got to Everett Donna's [ __ ] name is
Bubba in my far off you're not far off
oh my god is the Private Eye no no no
this this was like I was young like 18
to 23 so like I didn't know I had not
had very much sex yet so I just thought
oh all sex is kind of weird and whatever
but then I learned and I'm like I will
never do it again
obviously I'm married now again but the
worst time ever was this guy that was
supposed to be a hook-up so I was going
through a breakup and I just wanted to
have sex and I thought that guys would
be down to just like you know hook up
and no strings attached sex that's what
they always make it seem like this was
the second time that I told a dude like
hey I just want to have sex it was a guy
that I knew we did improv together and I
thought he was funny and I was like I'm
just down to have sex like I don't want
a relationship or anything like that I
don't want a date right now just like
just says oh my god imagine a girl as
hot as Nikki walking up if you're down
for some casual sex yeah just you know
let me know yeah Jenny goes to his Bros
it's [ __ ] disgusting bro I wanted a
relationship
Superman we were making out and I was
like okay just so you know I think this
is leading somewhere and like I just
like I'm down to have sex but not
anybody else and he was like yeah baby
whatever you want baby like I'll take
good care of you and I'm like okay just
I used to call me baby girl I like being
cold be like okay but by somebody that
you don't want a relationship with and
while they're [ __ ] me oh yeah this is
just like a hookup I just wanted to make
it very clear we're just friends after
this we're gonna just be friends like
nothing's gonna happen after this okay
so we were in the car making out and
like right outside of my apartment
building and so I'm like okay he's like
yeah that's I want to just have sex sure
so I'm like okay let's go up he like
parks the car really fast and he ends up
rear-ending in oh [ __ ] pillar behind
us like just like tries to park so fast
that he [ __ ] rear ends up on the back
of his car
like it's [ __ ] like okay and he's like
it doesn't matter and cross my face and
he just like MS making out with oh my
god like bites my why just so
aggressively like doesn't want the car
thing to ruin oh he's probably pissed
about the car taking it out and you know
I was like at this point I'm like I
really don't want this anymore but I
thought because he was gonna have to go
back to his [ __ ] oh you're saying thank
you see you're saying how I pity invited
him up because I was like well maybe you
could just go upstairs
chill for a little bit and he's like
yeah okay yeah yeah is that cool and I'm
like yeah so then we go up and he starts
immediately like aggressively making out
again like it's like that and feel that
it's like slipping yeah he just starts
biting my lip like ah I basically
offered to give him to like like go down
on him so you stop biting my [ __ ]
face baby goes down out there and it's
like full bush
microphone it wasn't hard yes it was
like it's like when you drop your cell
phone in my kids machete is Safari yeah
yeah and so I start with a [ __ ] and I
don't actually end up giving this guy a
[ __ ] think of because I was just like
so like we just I'm just gonna use my
hands for this yeah I use a condom
because I only don't use a condom if
we're actually in a relationship so I
had a condom I put that on we start like
going for it but I am so dry like I'm
like oh [ __ ] Sahara Desert dry like
not into this at all but this guy is so
like aggressively like um like enraged
in its passion and he's like sweaty and
I'm like in his own guy that I have no
no no weird case because I met one of
her exes at a party and this dude was
wearing a cape so then yeah so we
started voting he just starts dripping
sweat all over never him so bad like
what in fact he was just like very
Italian okay he was like a very hairy
and very Italian and you wouldn't expect
him I like looking at him he kind of
looked like John from the office or Jim
from the office yeah so I was like I'll
he's kind of cute and then when he and
then when this happened was like
destroyed everything so this is what I'm
seeing so you dated Bubba the truck
driver and then for some reason you had
a cape super pale vampire yeah and then
I was actually the break-up that I was
going through when I was hooking up with
this guy empire that was so you're
saying that he wrecked his car more than
you wrecked your [ __ ]
actually then we he went for like 45
minutes because he just 45 yeah he
thought that like girls wanted it longer
and I was like oh my god wrap this
common misconception yeah ya know like
I'm down for like 20 minutes or less and
like yeah 20 minutes on the long side to
see all right with that note we are
going on a break
we will be right back hold up alright so
let's talk about Buffy comforters
because Buffy makes this comforter
that's made out of eucalyptus and it
keeps you cool during the night and I
think that's so tight because I often
have to open the window or have the AC
on because Steve my husband is just like
a sweat monster and II just wake up just
like soaked in his sweat but with a
Buffy comforter
it keeps me cool during the night and I
think that's dope it's also uh earth
friendly and cruelty free there's no
more night sweats 100% plant-based
design its breathable keeps you
comfortable in a temperature that in a
way that polyester cannot do it's
hypoallergenic so a lot of people are
allergic to like down comforters stuff
like that this is you won't be allergic
to it and it's just like you couldn't
you can try a comforter in your own bed
for free and if you don't love it you
can return it for free yeah I want to
try that you know I'm one of them people
that like I like the fan on but I want
to be under the company yes yeah yes
America we are speaking merica comforter
fan America yes so um it's like being a
beautiful little koala wrapped up and
you can look this leaves that's nice I
like that you're so cute so we're $20
off your puffy comforter you can visit
Buffy Co and enter b tch again go to
Buffy CO and enter b tch
20 bucks off you can also try for free
and then return it if you don't like it
don't return it but don't you're gonna
love it
yeah and we're back Gina sorry [ __ ] no
I've had dude okay so I got invited over
to this guy's house right he was fine
like I'm the one who approached him
actually because I was waitressing at a
bar okay and I like to compliment people
I just do
you have to hit on you right but I told
my dude you're you're good-looking like
I don't want to hit on you but you're
good-looking but then you know one thing
led to another and we ended up hooking
up so I went over to his house it was a
nice house like it was nice but I think
he got it in his mind that women like
long sex cuz it was like oh yeah I'm
gonna [ __ ] you to the break of dawn and
then like so like an hour later I'm just
there like oh it's cuz they watch boring
yeah like I don't want warrants oh yeah
I want 20 minutes or less yeah all I
need like I and I like watching you come
so if I don't get to see you come I'm
like am i doing well we ended up not
even finishing both of us what yeah
because there's like went too long it's
gone too long actually that is one of
the issues with porn addiction - yeah
like you just can't finish oh I knew I
knew this guy that he was addicted to
hentai and so chemicals like he was
addicted to hentai and so like his girl
would have to like basically make weird
noises and then like she's like it was
like it's the weirdest thing like that's
such a bummer like can you imagine as a
woman like feeling like you're not sexy
but it's it's not you it's just there he
was not bad there's this one time I I
was okay so the same guy that sucked on
my toes look man he said to my toes I
didn't want to ruin the moment so I just
let him [ __ ] go what they just rocket
whatever and then like you could find
the pleasure in that time I think with
Buddhism I think either from like a
massage
yeah so we like the sex was great by the
way like the sex was great and then like
halfway through he's like wait I want to
use something I'm like okay cool and
then he goes to his drawer he pulls out
a dildo now for like a split second I
was like is this going into who's who's
just going into I don't know this is he
right now okay but it was for me and
that was the first time I ever used the
dildo before and that [ __ ] was dope
really I feel like in five years later
I'm hanging out with my girlfriends in
Taiwan we're like traveling and [ __ ] and
then we got to know realize that we knew
the same guy and then she was like I
hooked up with him I was like me too and
then he did this thing she goes
dil-don't was it the same dildo I'm like
it's not that one pink one he's like
hopefully he washes though yeah I mean
or maybe that's part of a fetish not
washing I know I made him clean it up
and then we just started busting out
laughs I was like can I tell you guys
like the fantasy that I've always wanted
but I've never been able to like do yes
please
so god we could do an entire episode on
almost gave you guys like a like worst
date story but like I was like that's a
whole another episode we're saving yeah
your story actually reminded me of the
same okay it's the Bubba
I just had to cancel sex immediately
boys he was going down on me and before
going down on me he goes like it I guess
and I think that man in porn they do
that yeah I immediately [ __ ] shut
down why would you do that that's so
cruel and like it and select like it's
fine if we're making out like I don't I
don't really what if it but like if I
see or feel or you know use you don't
spit on the dick Oh what if my god what
if we get her in a position where you
were being really submissive and the guy
was really dominant and he spit in your
mouth I had somebody text me and they
were like just spit you're like I never
thought when they spit do you spit or
swallow what's the next go it's what
happened to me once
okay hey it's only happen to me once and
it happened out of nowhere because me in
bed I like to be full-on dominated like
gyrate like [ __ ] break me [ __ ] like
I want to be disrespecting my girl Gio
knows I want to be slapped around like
backhanded everything so this dude was
on top of me and he was gonna be right
and then he like grabbed my face and
held my mouth open and just spat my
mouth and Hellboy and held it shut and
he's like you swallow that [ __ ] now I
was like I've been but land I was just
like I will never forget that ever do
you know for me like I I would so I
really love the whole choking thing and
I really like it when I'm being like
tossed around it's like yeah I want to
take you here and I want to you there
but when it comes to slapping my ass
I'm like no I'm pay attention to my butt
no touch it it doesn't do anything look
at me I'm just like oh that hurts
okay like a little pet instead of just a
full-on slap yeah um I don't like the
scent Oh for me to like I really don't
like hearing the sounds like for me
really I try to contain my my moaning
and stuff getting to me that's really
hot like I yeah I'm just like so [ __ ]
like having such a great time that I
don't want anyone else to know so I like
having really quiet sex okay so I'm I'm
the opposite I have really loud sex but
one of my biggest turn-ons
is when like they cover my mouth yeah
and be like I can't not loud yeah polar
opposite like because like I used to I I
can be very switch but and I used to
like I used to be like oh I want to be
dominated or like degraded or something
and then eventually I was like I don't
like that mm-hmm
just decided I was like I don't I don't
want you to do that to me but I just
started becoming more dominant and like
it's like dude it's really [ __ ] up I'm
like a predator like like if I'm really
into the guy I'm seeing like I will
objectify the [ __ ] out of them I'm like
you look [ __ ] good today
like that's I do that see like hey let
me see that dick real quick I'm I'm
literally like very like aggressively
like like I'm like you're mine yeah
scary and like you know I've heard that
like sometimes people are very dominant
in their personal life and then like
dominating both yeah because I'm [ __ ]
terrible in real life I am soulja
control fire control yeah yeah but in
bed you can [ __ ] talk me into a river
and I'll [ __ ] find you want that
being bossed around for this like them
one time I don't have to think about
anything how about being called a [ __ ]
during 1x I like I like it weighted as
[ __ ] yeah like for me that was a
complete turnoff it's like because
there's one town having sex this is one
guy he really liked to call me a [ __ ]
and a [ __ ] and I'm like I don't like
that does he call you that in real life
no no it was just like a sex thing I
guess like that turned him on and for me
like again I like to have like just
romantic really quiet no no it doesn't
have to be romantic it's just like I
don't want to talk really I don't want
to hear the sounds of like for example
slapping but if you're choking me it's
like I can't make a sound because I can
be choked so that I think that's my my
thing like I don't want to hear anything
mmm no I can be that you can call me you
can call me a broke [ __ ] with no
college I dig it I like I like like um
but I remember there are times when I've
struggled with my ex boyfriends because
it's like dude hit me harder like come
on I don't want these little [ __ ] slaps
or like their skip one dude told me like
I can't choke you like I I don't think I
can do that to you and I'm like that's I
ya body workout that's not gonna work
out for us yeah I think you know and I
think something that people don't really
talk about is I think that my sex I've
got significantly better when you know
in my personal life I learned how to
communicate really well like and work
and like with others and that translated
over into my sex life and I found out
unbeknownst to me that if you just tell
somebody what you like and what you
don't like you really cut a lot of the
[ __ ] like there's just I don't even know
why we have a stigma that like
we can't tell them like oh go there or
oh do this or like oh this is my spot or
something and then I learned like once
you do that like I'm like oh it's so
much better it is fun if they're
receptive they actually listen and
follow through I mean but yeah and this
is one of the few times where you know
particularly men will listen because
they want that porn star [ __ ] they want
like they want you to like finish they
want to make you feel good so if you're
saying hey here's the all-access pass
push this button they will push that
[ __ ] button like 80% of the time but
like if you're like hey you know I
really need to take out the trash like
that's not gonna make you finish so you
might not do that you know I feel like
when you're younger cuz you're still so
shy about your sexuality that you don't
talk about things like that but when you
get older you cut out all that [ __ ]
like on my second day be like this is
what I like this what I want this what
about you you know and it just gets that
[ __ ] out of the way you know exactly
what you want and I'm like much more
open about it now yeah I guess I'm
saying that because I had an experience
with someone where I was pretty vocal
with what I liked and what I didn't like
especially like during the act of things
but then it got to the point where he
got so in his own head where it's like
this is step one this is step two and
she wasn't like this [ __ ] wasn't like
that and like he was like walking on
eggshells whereas sex was just so like
it's like a puzzle oh yeah she was so in
his own head and it just it was not good
yeah I'm just like forget it and it's
also like where did you learn this from
a porn video great well I'm your teacher
now listen yeah yeah like porn stars are
the same and for the most part you both
want to please each other right so like
having a communication yeah you know
what that same guy he had issues with
letting me know what he liked
that's for me like it really turns me on
to know that he's turned on like yes
yeah like [ __ ] yeah like I want to make
you [ __ ] you know but like help me like
tell me what it is that you like the
most but I want you to know what you
didn't feel comfortable communicating
you like noise you like I don't like it
when I'm coming you know like give me a
warning earlier sounds like I do like
say you know like like I love that isn't
it yes we are the same I just don't like
being choked but I like my hand covering
my I've got I also like like like I
don't know if this is too graphic but I
like you know on the face
like facials yeah Nikki Nikki likes
feeling owned it looks like I'm I'm feel
like it's that possessiveness yeah I've
gotten choked out so hard once that
actually passed out and I came to like
oh [ __ ] right I woke up to him
[ __ ] me I was like oh I passed out
before and like I'm something like blood
blisters on my face pop blood vessel in
my eye and like yeah [ __ ] me up you know
what this is this is like these are your
best sex stories that like sounds like
the worst to other PDF yeah other people
who should have called 9-1-1 yeah I'm
good I've ever had for me like it really
gets me going if it's like so for me
it's not just silence like I like the
noises right but I would want the noises
to be like I'm trying to contain it yeah
like oh that's hot like oh we're gonna
be like grunts ooh but he's just like
yeah yeah I know like oh he's feeling it
yeah but he's trying to contain it you
know elbows on your mommy story and like
reminded me of something so my nose just
I'm not submissive at all told you like
I don't like being dominant however
there was this one time and that's why I
say like nothing's like a whole blanket
statement like you should never do this
for me because there was this one time
where it was like um it was this guy
that was like 10 years younger than me
okay or like not ten years it was like
eight years younger than me yeah and he
like was a virgin and we had like known
each other for a while and we had like
you know flirted a little bit and I like
kind of got - well he had sex with one
person right before me like right before
me but like it was pretty much like a
virgin and it was terrible sex like like
it wasn't good sex but it turned me on
to be like I'm helping him with his oh
wow
oh you know it's like I've seen guys
like that before it's just like oh my
god you're so innocent
yes I'm innocent yeah show you
everything and really for me it's like
it's too much work I want someone who
knows what they're doing you know I
think like psychologically I'm a similar
mindset like you know how I said that
you guys you want to be like dominated
and needed and like wah wah well if you
have a guy that's a little more innocent
and like looking up to you like that
you're still needed ya know yeah and
it's like and it's almost exciting
because it's like you're needed in like
a totally different kind of way yeah
sometimes I see you guys with like cute
baby faces like but there's still hands
and I'm like I will [ __ ] ruin you
it's gonna be great ass before it's
actually like when when Steve and I
first stated if you go back and look at
pictures of us in 2013 Steve was like a
skinny lanky dude without wore flannel
shirts and he had glasses I thought he
was more of a hipster nerd guy and I was
like this dude has never gotten his dick
sucked like I'm about to suck one of the
things that do you ever have you ever
dated a guy that you knew you were out
of his league but you liked that yes but
well yeah yes it's funny because I don't
have a type and I don't think I've ever
dated like a traditionally like mostly
handsome like jock but I like or any
like attractive like like that kind of
traditionally attractive guy
I see humor first like I've never been
attracted to someone before then making
me laugh once they make me laugh that
like deep hearted dark humor laughs then
I'm [ __ ] attracted to that and
they're the sexiest person I've ever
seen so a lot of times people will like
judge my boyfriend's like I dated one
guy that was five six he was like two
inches taller than me and he was pale as
a [ __ ] ghost and he was like maybe
laughs and so I dated him and I loved I
loved it and and then there's Steve
who's the exact opposite he's like six
four and he's like six strong and like
he's all that stuff and I love it on
both sides of the spectrum so I've dated
like six
put two tall dark and handsome muscular
that girls kind of threw themselves all
over him and in that in that
relationship I was like they're right
and then I've dated like not as
attractive and then that's what I'm more
dominant because I'm like where the [ __ ]
else you gonna go what else you know
[ __ ] get you know with like a lot of
like my friends and I've done it too or
like I dated a guy that was like he was
like maybe like a good five or six yeah
like personality wise like really great
and like this is gonna sound weird but
like I'm just trying to explain it
security is a major part of a
relationship it's a major factor that
you know both sides play a part in and
for you know me growing up as a very
insecure woman I can't date a 10 because
I don't want to be out in public with
you and worried yeah you know anybody's
gonna steal you at any given point so
it's this weird thought like deep and
I'm oh really it's more like I cannot
understand I cannot date like you know
if you're like too smart too successful
too hot too [ __ ] famous if you're
checking up all those boxes you're gonna
ruin my life and I'm not about it yeah I
don't want to go through that I dated a
guy briefly that was on Forbes and then
I was just like do you do you like me I
told him straight up Jim like she should
be dating like some like humanitarian
like something whatever he goes no dude
you're [ __ ] dope I'm like people like
you never know what people like refer
like you can't tell by the outside and
like know what their type is but the one
time I felt like that I dated a popular
guy in high school for like two months
this is a guy that like fell asleep
inside so but I would have let him do
whatever and I think I learned like I
learned a lot from that experience
because I was so I felt like he was so
out of my league I was like a god like a
punk rock like chubby girl with braces
and then like I got my braces off and
like I lost a couple pounds and then
this popular guy wanted to date me and I
was so freaked out in my head like I was
just like trying so hard to like make
him like me and like he already liked me
but like I which wanted him to think I
was cool too and like I was so [ __ ]
awkward yeah
that's why he ended but you're like at
nine coming too so I feel like my god
bows stop yeah you know no I was like I
was very like shy and uh I was more
tomboyish and he said that I he didn't
like that I wasn't girly enough and all
this stuff that's interesting like me
growing up though all the guys that I
ever dated
they were never guys that I wanted
nothing like Casey was the first person
that actually gave me butterflies and I
was excited I never ever dated a guy
that actually wanted somehow like I just
I was into deep girl where I'm like too
nice they end up like kind of like
kissing me and I'm like oh [ __ ] I guess
really kiss right now and then next
thing I know I'm in a relationship with
you never had a crush on you they just
know I really don't offend zone you're
like okay I guess you're nice you're
very going oh yeah me and tip for the
same and that because like I've dated
some guys were like I was like can
single he liked me I was like I'm
supposed to be dating so most of the
guys too for some reason like people
thought I had a type that I actually
liked big guys mm-hmm because a lot of
these guys were like pretty round plus
I'm like no it's just I don't know how I
get myself into these things like [ __ ] I
really just wanted date a really good
guy one time but I think that's what
builds you like now you know how to say
no or you learned how to say no and same
with like the dating out of your league
thing is like I will never let someone
just like completely be on a pedestal
like that we're like I'm so awkward
because I just don't I just want them to
like me so much
yeah you know one time I started
thinking about because someone asked me
once like what would you do if like I'm
just gonna say Jason Momoa it's just all
of us no I like every hole is available
whatever you want a little [ __ ]
bubble belly button watch no but you
know what for me though it's like what
you're saying but I just get really
insecure and I'm like you want me I
gotta run away like you're way too
[ __ ] loud like you're way too like up
there where I'm like I'm not worthy
serious question y'all ever dealt with
smegma yes yeah I saw it for my first
time in high school like I
was about to suck my boyfriend's dick
because you know high school you don't
have stood it smell it didn't smell bad
I and I pulled his foreskin back and I
was like you know what the [ __ ] is this
he goes oh no it's nothing just just do
it I'm like no no no yeah no first of
all [ __ ] we about to go to school
because I live right across my school so
it was don't you walk me to school every
morning I'm like no I'm not [ __ ]
doing that [ __ ] gross and I didn't know
what it was nasty
do you work things like that were like
you didn't realize well you realize that
then but like there's things that I
didn't realize it was bad sex or bad
anything until like now looking back
like I used to 69 a lot like before
having sex like I cuz I waited for a
year with my first boyfriend I was gonna
wait for marriage you know like I was
raised legit I was gonna I was trying to
wait for marriage and then I have been
dating this guy for a year in high
school and I was like we're probably
gonna get married anyway so then that's
when I decided lose my virginity but
during that year we did everything but
sex not but sex but like everything yeah
it was a lot of thought it was like yeah
yeah so I just it just hit me the other
day that I'm like man I used to really
love that yeah have you ever had dude
have you ever gotten someone so [ __ ]
fine there's this one dude that was so
fine like this is one of the very can't
relate oh sorry my boyfriend yeah it was
like one of those few really rare times
when I got shy whenever he came around
cuz this fool was like a Korean like
model right like he was fun my girl like
oh my god muscles and tattoos he like he
was
beautiful look the mommy guy looks like
a k-pop stars and to say I'm still like
God he's cute yeah he's cute no see him
and I'm just like damn like it was it
was like a it was it was so it was a it
was a Korean guy but he had a black
guy's name for some reason I don't even
know why but he was fine and then it
turned out to be one of the most
disappointing sex I've ever had in my
life ever like because he's been so
pretty he's never had to like yeah yeah
yeah it was so boring that I swear to
god I almost picked up my phone and
texting my girlfriend like during it
yeah dude and then like I don't even
spend that I'm like I'm gonna yeah yeah
one disappointing one sex is too boring
or too long I start like going through
my to-do list for the next yeah like
what groceries I need I'm like ah [ __ ] I
gotta get bananas I'm out of bananas and
that any laundry quarters yeah I have at
the bananas I'll just get the roller
cord and like they and then I realize
I'm just in the middle of sex
really I know for me it's the opposite
where I'm just like so in that shitty
sex moment where I'm like damn this
sucks why are you doing that no go over
there what the [ __ ]
No get me out of here like that sucks
for y'all I don't experience that I dude
my my boyfriend is so out of my league
that like I made me less crazy because
like in all my other relationships I
didn't care so I didn't try and then
like after like the second or third date
I was like I really like this line I was
like I want to keep this one and so like
it kept me from like you know when I
would get mad about something I'd be
like all right man let's shut the [ __ ]
up like somebody someone you're crazy
died yes yeah like like solutely that's
next level but like with anyone else
like I was like I was [ __ ] insane
because I didn't give a [ __ ] about that
yeah you know what I mean and so in like
now I'm like I mind I mind my business
is good I think we've gotten into like
we've been dating for a year now I think
we got it into one maybe two art no one
argument and then one long form of
communication O'Day makeup sex is so
good though dude oh I go bad you just
pick a fight
I was thinking because I feel like but
like no I feel like we'd be like really
not in the mood right now sweetheart
yeah yeah how do you lead to make up sex
because I haven't really had that really
really be so passionately angry at the
person were you [ __ ] hate them you're
screaming and then like that passion is
not a dissimilar feeling to the passion
of hot sex yeah and so you just like
convert it it's just like how fear is
very close to the feeling of excitement
you can so if you're nervous about
something you can shift that into being
excited about something you could shift
anger yeah oh yeah I back any morning so
well not sound healthy no it was but it
gets it all out hmm yeah I could do that
because I'm just if I'm mad I'm just
like [ __ ] you till the ends of the earth
like don't come near me
don't I think what it is though so when
we're having sex I'm like no don't like
that I'm turned on by that like being
like no no I don't want it fighting like
it's like it's even more like no [ __ ]
you got me oh [ __ ] you know it's really
weird so during sex are usually really
submissive but but there is one way to
get me angry during sex that I start
like that's how I ended up back hand and
my dude so for those of you who remember
like way back in asked the feels I can
squirt like a porn star Jesus I could I
can control it you can yeah well there
are times when it's like when it's
really good I can't control it but Venus
I hear pinion on people like if it's for
me it's like more like for show right
it's like for show that but it when it's
like when he hits the really good spot
then I can't control it it just happens
to come out and then that gets me pissed
because the weird way in my head is
you're [ __ ] up my sheets [ __ ] oh my
god then I get angry and then I'm like
what the [ __ ] and then we start [ __ ]
even harder and then I backhand you and
I get angry and then they got on top and
I started writing the [ __ ] out of that
dick Wow I'm usually submissive but if
you ever want me to get angry just make
me squirt like this
you guys she's wearing you guys are like
my sisters and then hearing you say
stuff like that and the David was
talking about how he watched an episode
I asked it feels one time in geo was
like yeah and almost grinded all my [ __ ]
and he was like I can't watch it
I feel except I'm here in real time
can't get away well there you go guys
those are all of our worst sex stories
if you like [ __ ] like this you should
definitely subscribe go rate us on
iTunes or wherever you are also
subscribe to our personal stuff there's
other girls that are involved Supes stay
tuned for the next episode there's gonna
be new faces new topics if you have a
topic you would like us to talk about
message us comment say something yeah we
got to talk about worst dates fetishes
other crazy [ __ ] tweet us life advice
business oh wait for the fetish episode
I'm about to [ __ ] all you guys I just
want to say it for $80 off your first
month of hellofresh go to hell afresh
calm slash b tch for $20 off your puffy
comforter visit Buffy CO and enter b tch
thanks guys bye eBay